>> Please welcome, Director of
Data Science Microsoft
Research, Vani Mandava.
>> Hello everyone, and welcome to
these last two sessions
of Faculty Summit 2018.
So in 2017, 57% of
professional occupations in
the United States
were held by women.
Yet, only 17% of
Fortune 500 CIOs positions
were held by women.
In computing specifically,
only 26% of jobs
were held by women.
The numbers are even lower for
under-represented
groups Black and
Hispanic men for example,
hold only nine percent
of computing jobs,
and the numbers for
black and Hispanic women are
an abysmal four percent.
As a result,
the technical products
and services that we use
today had been created by
a single large homogenous
group of people, men.
Considering the impact
that technology
has on our economy,
our society, and our lives,
it makes sense to pause
and consider the question,
what if women and other
groups under-represented
in technology we're at the table,
designing and creating
technology alongside men?
This bundle of computing
innovators will explore
the exciting outcomes that are
possible if diverse perspectives
were brought to the table.
It is my pleasure to
introduce Lucy Sanders,
our esteemed moderator for
this distinguished panel.
Lucy Sanders, the CEO
and co-founder of
the National Center for Women
and Information Technology
and [inaudible].
Lucy has extensive
industry background
having worked in R and D,
and executive VP positions
at AT and T Labs,
Bell Labs and Avaya
Labs for over 20 years.
Lucy specialized in systems that
has software and solutions,
and also hold six patents in
the area of communications
technology.
Lucy is the recipient of
the very prestigious Bell Labs
Fellow Award which is
the highest technical
accomplishment
bestowed at the company.
Lucy currently serves as
a trustee for the
Colorado School of Mines,
The Center of
American Entrepreneurship
in Washington DC and
the International Computer
Science Institute
at the University of
California Berkeley.
She has served on
the information technology
research and development
ecosystem commissioned for
the national academies and the
innovation Advisory Board for
the US Department of Commerce.
On behalf of Microsoft,
it is a great honor to welcome
Lucy Sanders and
our distinguished panel
for this session.
>> Oh thanks Vani for
that really great welcome,
and welcome to Jim and
Margaret and Abolade
for coming today and sharing
some insights around
diversity and innovation.
As a community, those of us in
computing and all of us
are I think in this room.
We will talk about broadening
participation in computing,
quite a bit when we get together,
and often we'll talk about
it as a pipeline issue.
We need to focus on the
computing educational pipeline,
and that's true, we do.
That's a very important
thing or we'll talk
about it as being
the right thing to do,
well-paying jobs for
a diverse group of people,
a workforce issue and those
are all true as well.
But today, we're not
going to talk about
any of those important things.
We're going to talk
today about the link
between innovation and diversity.
It's often a conversation
we don't stop and have,
and when you think about,
it it's the real reason
why we're in this game.
It's not just a numbers game.
We want to see what great
creative ideas
would come to the table when
diverse populations are there.
So, the link between
innovation and diversity,
between creativity and diversity,
between great research
outcomes and diversity
are really important things
that this panel will explore.
Everybody on the panel today is
a noted innovator and
his or her own right,
and also somebody who cares
deeply about diversity and
inclusion or my favorite
new word belonging.
You know, where you are
working and where
you are studying.
So, it's a super important
topic because we
know from research and Vani
mentioned some of this
in her opening remarks,
that diverse teams solve
complex problems faster and
they get to a better answer.
They are also have
higher collective intelligence in
problem solving as well.
It's very important that
these diverse teams be very well
managed because homogeneous teams
are often easier to manage.
But they don't necessarily get
to the most innovative outcome.
So, it's important that they be
really well managed as well.
So, I know these are
things we all care about
and our panelists
care about it too.
So we're going to start the
questioning with a little bit
of storytelling here because
I think it's important to
establish this link from
their broad perspective
this as innovators,
about the links
they've seen between
technical innovation
and diversity.
So, I'm going to ask each one.
We'll go first to Margaret.
Thank you, Margaret.
To talk about a technical project
or team they were involved
in that had particularly
innovative results.
So the link between
innovation and diversity.
So Margaret,
tell us about your story and
we're going to geek out.
So, we're going to
really be talking
about technology
really geek out here.
So, go ahead Margaret.
>> Sure. Thanks. So, it's
wonderful to be here.
I guess rather than think
about one zoomed in,
I'm going to talk about an
overall culture that's been in
my research group over
the 25 years now,
nearly that I've
been at Princeton,
and that is about projects
that are interdisciplinary,
and so there's
a diversity of topic,
a diversity of
skill sets that come in,
and then a diversity
of backgrounds
and genders and so forth as well.
So, about a little
over 15 years ago,
I started a project called
ZebraNet that was basically
started because I a computer
systems person who cared
about power efficiency.
Got coupled with one of
my biology colleagues from
across campus who wanted
better wildlife tracking devices.
We worked across that
intellectual gap to come up with
designs that abided by
their needs and
their desires to get better,
fine-grained tracking
of zebras and abided
by the engineering constraints
to the problem which
was very tough,
power constraints, and
GPS limitations, and so forth.
Coupled in all of that was
a diversity of people as well,
because you bring in people
with conservation experience,
you bring in people with
deep engineering experience,
male, female, different
parts in the stack.
I think it was
a very a fertile place
to have group meetings
because you'd
have to explain things
carefully across
those lines which makes
you a better communicator,
but you also come up with
interesting research ideas that
lie in the interstices between
different topic areas.
>> I think it's
the first time I've heard
diversity being
different parts of the stack.
It's pretty fun Margaret.
Well, Jim, what about
you? Tell us your story.
>> Okay. Well, before
I say a story,
I have to set the stage
for the story, right?
>> Okay. Of course.
>> I think something
that we're seeing in
computing now is a sort of
a move from computing being tools
to computing being
partners with people.
At the National
Science Foundation
where I'm working right now.
We talk about the human
technology frontier and we talk
about technology that
really means computing.
Maybe we shouldn't say that to
everybody across
the National Science Foundation.
But that's science, that's
what we think about,
and when we think about
the human technology frontier,
it's all of humanity.
So in a sense, I take it
to be really axiomatic
that if we're
building tools that
we're going to
partner with as humans
that it's going to be
for all of humanity.
So it's axiomatic that
we want to embrace and
engage across
all different aspects
of diversity whether
it be cultural,
socio-economic, gender,
however you measure it.
So, my story, my favorite
project I worked on,
actually it was all the way
up and down the stack also.
At the University
of Massachusetts,
we had a project on
collaborative adaptive
sensing of the atmosphere.
It was about the
system concept versus
a dense network of low-powered
radars that would sense
hazardous weather and predict
and do early warning and
detection of hazardous weather
and learning how to folks.
To me that's
sort of a quintessential
socio-technical smack at the dab,
smack dab at the human
technology frontier,
and it was diverse.
So yes, I went all the way
up and down the stack,
all the way from
designing wave forms to
deciding when to issue
warnings to people.
It was also diverse
in the backgrounds of
people who were there.
We had meteorologists, we
had computer scientists,
that was me in the terms
of the leadership,
meteorologists,
computer scientists, atmospheric
scientists, sociologists,
electrical engineers, all
working side by side.
We had, let's see,
an Asian- American, that was
me and the Indian-American,
we had a Latino and African-American
and two white males
in our leadership team.
So, I think we just had
incredible diversity in that,
and I think of all of the
projects that I've worked on,
to me that was the
most rewarding because
of all of the diverse viewpoints,
we had to bring to
solve that and system.
All the way from
designing radar forms,
all the way up to
doing notifications.
>> So interdisciplinary
also seems to be
coming out in
this conversation as well.
So, Abolade, tell us your story.
>> I also have
an interdisciplinary story.
So, we see, I think
the things that you shared,
Gem and Margaret,
really resonated.
The project that I'm thinking
about is project Rome,
which was an effort that we
started to really rethink how
you interact with your computer
in a world where you
don't just have one,
where you have several.
You're doing things on
your mobile device,
you are doing things
maybe on a laptop,
maybe you have a workstation
where you do other things.
As we got started
on this project,
one of the first things
that we did is we assembled
a team; folks from marketing,
folks from user
experience design,
folks like me who
are plumbers who
understand the operating system
and communications,
and we started by trying
to tell the story.
What we found was that
by trying to tell
this story first,
that multidisciplinary approach,
we picked the problems
that we wanted to
solve in a much better way
and we were able to focus.
Some of you may have seen we
launched a feature recently
called "Your Phone",
that lets you link your phone and
PC and use them seamlessly,
get messages on your PC,
see photos on your PC
from your phone.
That in a lot of ways is the
culmination of a journey that
started from taking
a slightly different approach.
Traditionally, in
the operating system,
we would start with
the technology,
and then we would go
looking for the problem.
In this case, I think
it was eye-opening,
how much of a difference it
made in the final result,
just assembling
a different set of
perspectives at an early phase,
in going after a problem.
>> Excuse me. So,
it's so interesting,
I love operating systems too.
I'd rather just do
operating systems,
let the problems find
me, that's more fun.
Just a joke. Anyway, so
when I was at Bell Labs
in the early 90's,
I did a project,
it was a Multimedia
Communication Server Enterprise.
It was a mash-up between Skype
and Google Docs in 1993,
and the team was hugely
diverse: racial diversity,
gender diversity, all kinds
of ethnicities on this team.
It was really that project
that got me thinking about,
I was a bit of a slow learner,
you're like "Wait a minute.
Wow. This is awesome,
all these different
kinds of people."
All of us had great diversity,
and a lot of that came because
we hired really smart thinkers,
mathematicians, scientists,
and they learned how to
create hardware and software.
Yes, so, it was very diverse.
It was a really
interesting project.
Though unfortunately,
not all teams are this way,
we know from our stats,
and I'm going to give you
a few stats just to put
a little foundational
grounding under this.
I'm going to give you some
stats that are about gender,
but I also want to
reinforce again,
we need stats on all
groups participation.
There are number of historically
marginalized groups in computing,
in this particular case
and these case studies,
and what they really
tell you, the
process we really
only look at gender.
But, their innovation metrics
are different than
participation metrics
which makes them
different than the ones
we normally look at.
So, this is really around
more meaningful
participation in computing.
So, NC runs a patenting study,
we update it every
couple of years.
We crawl the US Patent database
with gender matching software,
and we assign a gender to
every inventor on every IT patent
and then we look at the results.
IT is a government's
definition of IT,
so it's all things computing.
It's everything in
the computing community,
and end result over
the last 30 years:
88 percent of all patents have
male only invention teams,
well, that's one or more men,
two percent have
female only invention teams,
and the rest are mixed.
So, of course, patenting is
only one innovation metric.
We did the same thing on
the ACM paper database,
for papers accepted to
ACM conferences and we did
the same type of thing,
that N of over 600,000,
it was a pretty big N,
and about 78 percent of
all authors on
accepted papers to ACM,
about 78 percent are
male and the rest are
female, 22 percent.
Now, that number's not,
you'd like it to be higher,
let's just face it.
But it's not so bad when you
consider women's participation in
Computing Faculty in
major research institutions.
It tracks about what
you would expect,
but the real thing on
this particular study was
the sub-segregation of papers
between women and men.
Women were mostly in
documentation human computer
interface not systems,
not networking, not algorithms.
So, huge sub-segregation.
Real quickly, just to let you
know, overall
participation numbers,
women make up about 13 percent
of all hardware developers
and about 18 percent of
all software developers.
So, it's pretty safe to
say with numbers like
these and others,
that we're missing out on
a large set of
creative ideas from
over half the population
when it comes to
innovation and research in
the areas we care about.
So, that's like
a huge untapped potential
that if we could just
figure out what to do here,
there's an innovation gap,
and a huge upside
potential if we solve it.
So, my second question is
going to be, if I get to it.
Here we go, as panelists and
as innovators yourselves,
why do you think it's
critical to close
this innovation gap?
You've hinted at some of that in
the answers to
your first questions,
why do you think it's
critical to close
this and why do you
think we have this?
Why do you think it's happening?
I'm going first Abolande
>> Alright.
>> Yeah.
>> The word that comes to
mind to me when I think about
the importance of diversity
in innovation, is robustness.
If you think about an idea
as a living thing,
it's survivability
depends heavily
on its composition at birth.
Ideas that come out
of diverse teams,
ideas that reflect at
birth a set of
diverse perspectives,
not just a coder's
perspective on
what algorithm he can write,
but say a marketing
person's perspective on
what things matter to end users,
human-computer interaction
specialists' perspective
on what is usable,
a man's perspective, a
woman's perspective,
an African's perspective,
various backgrounds.
When all of those are present
at the birth of an idea,
it's the likelihood
that it will not
die on the way to
adulthood is much higher.
I think that metaphor
is helpful because,
really I think what we care
about is not just innovation,
but innovation that has impact.
Innovation that has impact
has the characteristic,
to me at least,
that there are things that
have been thought through and
incorporated at
every stage along the way,
that really can
only get in there,
that can only really be woven in,
if you have a set of
diverse perspectives that
reflects the world in which
that idea is going to actually
exist. There was
another question.
>> I know. It's
a double-barreled question
which is really unfair.
So, the second part
of the question was,
why do you think
we have this gap?
>> I think it's familiarity.
I think that the easiest thing to
do is what you tend
to see the most of.
I think it takes real effort
to apply a
multidisciplinary approach.
I think it takes
real effort to number one,
identify a lack of
diversity and then
number two, correct it.
You have to be intentional
about it and I
think that without
the right mindset
and without the right
framework around
optimizing for diversity
in our approach,
I think the default behaviors
tend to dominate.
>> So, I might answer
the second question first
by how did we get here?
I think it ties back to this
this notion of the human
technology frontier,
and a shift from focusing
more on computing, and databases,
and operating system
networks as artifacts,
and more now towards computing,
partnering with humans, and
more on the application side.
I think, we were able
to maybe slide by
without as much diversity
before because it was more
looking at artifacts.
Now, if we're building
technologies that are going
to partner with humans,
there's just absolutely
no way we can
get by without
that firstly perspectives.
>> I think that's
a really good point.
Margaret, what what do you think?
>> I wanted to zoom in on
a particular part of
the timeline which is
the time from late in a PhD
onwards into one's career.
I want to zoom in
in particular on
the systems research
community writ large.
I want to say that it is really
easy to think about
the numbers that we have
in our undergrad programs,
which thankfully, are
coming back up again.
Actually, first thing
is concrete example.
I represent the peak year in
terms of percentage
production of women,
CS bachelor's degrees in America.
I'm 53 years-old,
the peak was 1986.
We came back down for many,
many years, and now
we're coming back up.
So, first of all,
there's this notion that
the pipeline will save us,
but the pipeline was draining.
Second of all, the other
part of it is that
PhD production has
hung in there at
around 15 to 20% women for
many years because we
refill internationally,
even though US numbers
undergrad have fluctuated.
So, you look in a later part
of the career and you say,
"We could've been
sort of sustaining
about 20% participation in
our systems research community."
But if you look at
the ACM sig membership numbers,
of the sigs that we
represent in this room,
SigOps, SigPlan and SigCom
have less than five
percent women membership.
SigArch comes in, that's my sig
at around eight percent,
and kudos to SigMobile which
tops out just above 10%.
So, something's
happening in how we're
cultivating the second
part of a person's career.
Like we get them to the point
of getting a PhD but do we
cultivate what sustains
them longer term than that,
that's not as clear to me that
we are doing as
much in the way of
long-term mentoring, and
long-term appreciation.
I think the first step is,
as sustenance researchers we
measure what we care about.
So, we should be measuring more
of this data in ongoing way.
We should get it for
under-represented groups,
so that we can see
at a conference,
how many of the first authors
presenting the paper were women?
Are under-represented minorities?
It's often very small,
and it's very hard to know.
So, I think better data
tracking used to
motivate that mentorship and
sustained career development
would be great.
>> You're touching
someone culture.
So, we again, to really not
focus on the educational
pipeline but what happens after.
I can say a bit about the
workforce, corporate workforce.
One of the biggest
things that we hear
there on hospitable culture,
when you start to
really dig into that,
you find out that, for example,
women tend to be more in
the support roles that support
the creative endeavors
of innovators.
So they would be in
project management
system verification,
customer requirements,
very important things by
the way, don't get me wrong.
Super important, but they're
not the things that would lead
generally to a promotion
up the technical ladder.
So, what happens that to
be a CTO, or an architect,
or distinguished engineer,
they just don't lead
there, generally speaking.
So, by mid-career they get
frustrated and they leave.
So, they're not even
at the stage of
their career yet where
they could be innovators.
They don't have
the task assignments.
When you drill down into
that, while the supervisors,
technical supervisors really
have no idea how they assign
roles, tasks, assignments etc.
So, those are the kinds of
things we have to
really start being
curious about and
all the people are analytical.
You all have a great
spirit of inquiry.
If we start really getting
a data, and digging into it,
and being curious about it,
as Margaret is saying,
and look for some of the ways we
can take bias out of
some of these systems,
I think the gap will will close.
But we have to really be curious
and analytical about it.
Just in the same
when you are around
cloud computing or anything else.
So, that's what we
see in the workforce,
and I suspect it's somewhat
true in academia as well.
Will anybody want to comment
on what the culture is like
for young researchers
and old researchers,
or new PhDs in academia?
>> So, I'm a lifelong
unapologetic academic.
I love it.
I think it's the best job
in the world.
Frankly, I think we do
an okay job in many ways
of cultivating
our young faculty members.
I sometimes worry that
we don't explicitly say
how much fun we're having.
I try to explicitly say
how much fun I'm having.
Because I think people
need to see that.
You want to engage in
a path that: A) shows
impact and B) looks enjoyable.
So, I try to model that
more explicitly myself.
I think in academia,
there are flexibilities to
the way you operate
groups and the way
so you manage your time that
are incredibly compelling.
Getting the word out about
that is super important.
>> So, tell us what NSF
doing in this space?
You're well known for
broadening participation.
>> Let me answer
the NSF question.
But I will say that
like Margaret,
I'm a lifelong academic
and absolutely love it.
Many of the challenges
that I think we face with
diversity in computing
are faced across,
really across the university.
My sense is that universities
are becoming more
attuned to that,
and more flexible in hiring
and tenure processes.
So, I see some light at
the end of the tunnel there.
Let me put on my NSF hat and say
a couple words about NSF.
So, there's a long history.
Well,10 years I suppose
it's not that long,
but certainly a recent
and really storied
history of activities here
in broadening participation
in computing there,
the BPC alliances like
NC Whit, like CRAW,
access computing cache
and others,
and these have been
ongoing activities for 10 years
that I just think I've
been absolutely fabulous.
There are mentoring program,
so Margaret mentioned
the importance of mentoring.
At the undergraduate level,
career mentoring,
grad women's cohorts,
so projects and
activities like that.
We're not talking much
about the pipeline
but I can't help
but mention "Computer
Science for All,"
and we'd like to
really say "For all"
to emphasize the equity and
the access to
rigorous and really compelling
computer science education
in K 212,
and that's an activity that
we're really, really proud of.
One of the things that's
happened there in addition to
the ECS computing that
folks may have heard about,
the computer science principles,
a second AP exam,
this offered
the first time in 2017.
Fifty thousand students took it,
between what, 2017 and 2016,
the number of students
taking the AP exam,
either the AP exams and
computer science
more than double,
the number of women
more than doubled,
the number of Hispanic students
the number of
African-American students.
So, I think that speaks
really well for the pipeline.
I will tell you since many
of you are academics here,
the challenge is going to be when
those students show up on
our academic doorsteps.
Are we going to have
programs that welcome them,
and the kinds of computing
that that they want to do.
I see that as a challenge.
I think as wonderful
as those are,
sometimes it's too easy
to sit here and say,
"Oh, look at all those great
things that are going on.
The Lucy Sanders
of the world will
take care of BPC for us. "
They do wonderful things.
But it's a challenge
for all of us I
think in looking out here,
all of us here have
a responsibility and
a need to address that.
So, a new program actually that
we're piloting at
the National Science Foundation,
I know many people
here don't read
the dear colleague letters
that I write,
but you should read
dear colleague letter
17110 on engaging in
meaningful broadening
participation activities.
What we're trying to do
here is to make this,
what we NSF are
trying to do here,
we've piloted this in
the very large grants,
we're going to pilot it
next year in some of
the select mediums,
and enlarge grants.
The idea here is that
everybody who's funded under
an NSF grant should take part in
some meaningful BPC activity.
It doesn't mean you have
to go out and start
the next MC whit or CRAW.
But there's something
that every one of us can
do to help broaden participation.
It can be in many
of the ones that
Margaret just
mentioned, for example.
So, we're really very
excited about that.
So, if I could leave
you with one thought,
had been a teacher
for 32 years I guess,
if you walk away with one thing,
here's one thing to walk away.
Read dear colleague letter
17110 or send me an email
and I'll send it to you.
>> That's great. What's
the number again?
>> 17110.
>> Okay. [OVERLAPPING]
>> If we have this first,
I'll have the number
there on the slide.
>> We should put it on
announcement stab or
the Microsoft research
faculty research,
say that would be great.
I want to just throw in
a one question before I
ask the final question
because I don't want
to leave the panel
without maybe ask you for
a few observations on
what the researchers will
call intersectionality.
The notion that we all
identify in different ways
and multiple ways.
That in fact, I could be
a white woman from the South,
or I could be a black man
from New York City,
all different
intersecting identities.
So, we don't want to leave
you with the notion that
there's like a shopping list
of things you can do,
a proper broadening
participation.
They have to be very
thoughtfully done.
So, anybody, any thoughts on this
or think it's
a super important topic
to just make sure people know
that word intersectionality,
and how we can't just assume
all women are the same,
or all blacks are the same,
or Latinas are the same.
>> I guess I would again
stress that as Lucy just said,
it shouldn't be a checklist
that you should find
something that you want to do,
and actually engaging in
existing structures and what
people will call scaffolding.
So, maybe there is a CSTA
that you can engage with.
Or maybe your department
or your college
is doing something that
you can engage in.
It's not like you have to
go out and do a checklist,
"Oh, I better go do x."
Find something that's
meaningful for
you that you can relate
to because that's
the contribution that
will make a difference to
people who are on the receiving
end of that contribution.
>> Any thoughts on that one?
>> I guess I would add, when
I'm running a research group,
one of the things I
try to be aware of is,
having enough diversity along
many dimensions that everybody in
the end can just be themselves,
it doesn't feel like
a dominant group in a outsider.
>> Super important.
>> In the process, you end up
with a weightlifter who
happens to be female,
and a quiet Harry Potter male
and everyone is allowed
to be individuals,
because there isn't
a dominant culture
and a recessive or
outsiders feeling.
>> Again, returning to
the word belonging,
and I think that's everybody
wants to belong and
contribute and do
the best work of their lives.
So, it's super important.
So, let's do one last question
to each panelists.
We're starting with
Abalode. One idea,
Jim already gave us his,
so you get another one.
>> Oh, wow, I thought I
wasn't going to get one.
>> Yeah, you're going to
repeat the same one if you
really want to emphasize that.
One idea that you can
take out of this room
today and do immediately,
that doesn't cost much money.
For a broadening participation
as it relates to
innovation and diversity.
Again, I think you all
really want to come
back and hit that.
You know that where we have
the biggest gap in many ways,
the pipelines is
some sense filling, right?
>> Yes.
>> We're starting to see more
of these students arrive.
We want them then in
their research careers,
or in their corporate careers
to be able to innovate,
and to create, and to bring
their best life
experiences to the table,
and do really great
technology work.
So, what would be one thing
that you could leave people
with that they could do?
>> Can I say two things?
>> Yes, just like Jim, you
want to be just like Jim?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, all right.
>> So, the two things
for me really are,
be an advocate and
set an example.
We have an internal
conference here at
Microsoft called the Whips.
It's by invitation only.
It's our top technical
conference and I
remember there was a few
years ago, Galen Hunt,
whom some of you, you
may know stood up at
Whips during the session for
poster talks and he said,
"Look around the room."
Everyone looked around
the room and he said,
"There aren't
very many women here,
and I think that's a problem and
so what I would
like you to do is,
the next time you want
to invite me to Whips,
take my invitation and give
it to one of our women
engineers instead."
And he sat down and I thought
that was really great.
I think that all of us
have the ability to
affect decisions that are
made daily in our contexts,
in a positive direction.
It's a tool that is relatively
cheap for us to exercise.
So, that's the first thing
that I would leave folks with is,
look at conference selection,
settings, paper selection
and just be an advocate.
The second one is,
set an example.
What I mean by that is that,
when you are assembling
a team along
the lines that
Margaret mentioned,
be intentional by looking
at the set of people that you
have around you and asking,
"Am I defaulting to
the same choices?
Are there people whom I'm
not even considering?
Is the set of perspectives
that I have actually diverse?"
The reason to do that is,
because the statistics
that we're looking at,
they don't come out of a vacuum.
They actually come
out of the set of
people who are in
this room, writ large.
And the way in which
those statistics change is that,
all of us exercise
back pressure against
our default tendencies.
>> That's absolutely
right. Absolutely right.
>> I guess I have
to do two now too.
>> The pressure is on.
>> I like to keep up.
>> I get it.
>> Right. So, one that's
super cheap and it just
requires you to remember is,
I think we lose track
of how much students
and people junior to
us responds to even modest
tiny bits of feedback.
So, the quick email at
the end of the class,
or after a mid-term,
that says, "You would be
great if you continued
on in this field.
You would be great if you
considered grad school."
It's a 10-word email and it
will make a difference
in someone's life often.
Even if they don't do
what do you think
they'd be great at,
they've heard it I
guarantee you. That's one.
The second thing is that
by virtue of who we are,
we're fairly senior and so we're
more often in the position of
being allies to things
that are going on,
than being in the
picked on situations
ourselves these days.
So, I would encourage you
to look at the world with
your ally hat on and
remember to say things like,
"I didn't find that funny,
we don't do that here," you
don't have to be
completely humorless,
but you can be the grownup in
the room that just
raises the bar,
don't wait for the
picked on person to
have to say it themselves. I
think those would be my two.
>> Very important. All right,
Jim, you only get one.
>> Well, those were
really good answers
and actually I note that,
it's all about people and
their individual connections.
I think when I was
listening to Abalode,
I thought, "Oh, that's
exactly my answer."
So, my answer is the same as his.
I'd use two different words
and that would
be a mentor and be a role model.
Right? As Margaret said,
just reaching out to
somebody and talking to
them and helping and
that could be a student,
it could be a colleague,
it could be a staff, it could be
lots of different people.
That personal touch really makes
a huge difference and to
be a role model as well,
and I think people
as Margaret said,
many people here
are senior people,
look to us and how we behave
and I think that's
really important.
There are lots of different ways
to be a role model,
and being a mentor and
being a role model
is absolutely no cost at all.
>> So, I guess I get
two. I'll take two.
One would be become- this
sounds like a really simple
one but you'd be surprised
how often it's not done.
Use the spirit of
inquiry that we all
have to challenge
things in a nice way.
So, it's like a question.
So, when somebody says,
"I don't think Lucy is qualified
for that award," spirit
of inquiry will say,
"Well, what makes
you think that?"
Or, "I don't think
that Abalode is a
natural born leader."
Well, what's that mean anyway?
What do you mean by that?
One more question, not to say,
"Oh, you're wrong," or argue
that can come later, right?
But just a question in
that learning moment to
find out what do they mean?
Because we say things
all the time and we have
no idea what they mean,
and it's a learning moment
for both people.
Because it could be that,
Lucy is not a natural
born leader, right?
I mean, that might well be.
By the way I don't think
there is anything as a natural
born leader, but anyway.
So, the spirit of inquiry
is underrated and all of us
are researchers and
innovators and we know
how to do that and
it's just a question.
It's the same question you
would ask technically,
"Why do you think that works?"
Or whatever. So,
the spirit of inquiry
I think is super important.
The other thing I want to say is,
you don't have to do this alone.
There are a lot of free resources
and programs out there.
There are some programs
that cost a little money,
but lots of ways to be involved
and see what has them.
CRAW has them, ACMW has programs.
There are a lot of
great programs out there to
give you research
based information.
So, that's the last idea
here is, go become informed.
This is not a heavy lift for all
of you smart people to go and
become informed about what
social science research
says about under representation.
Then you're going to be well
equipped to use
your spirit of inquiry.
If you don't know what
unconscious bias means from
a research perspective,
stereotype threat, civility,
collective intelligence,
inter-sectionality,
they're like 10 words you
can find out very easily
and then you'll be
very well equipped
to base your actions on research.
So, those are our ideas
and I think we've got
a few minutes for questions,
Q and A if people have
any questions from the audience.
I see somebody with
their hand up there.
Wait a minute, someone is
coming to you, I believe.
>> Thank you all
for your comments.
The one thing that I didn't
hear talked about was,
diversity inclusion with
respect to disability,
and I was wondering if
you would just take
a minute to address that
and how we can aid in
DNI for disability.
>> Well, first of all,
right down the road you'd
have there Richard Ladner-
>> Access Computing, right.
>> -who runs Access Computing.
Yes. Do you want to
say more about that?
>> I will just say,
one of the seven
BPC activities is,
Access Computing,
which really aimes
specifically at exactly that.
As Lucy mentioned
that's been led for
quite a long time
by Richard Ladner,
he is an amazing guy at UW.
>> The other thing
I'll say too is,
we just discovered
a gap in working with
Richard and a researcher
Maya Israel,
who looks a lot at
Universal Design.
And have discovered
a pretty big gap
right now in terms of
computing curriculum
and Universal Design
for students with
learning disabilities.
So, Richard works quite a bit
on physical disabilities
and he's starting to look
at learning disabilities,
and so that's a thing
to think about.
Like, how could we
possibly create
curriculum homework
assignments et cetera,
that enables students with
different learning
disabilities to
succeed in our classrooms.
>> I'll just add, so CRAW has for
over 15 years offered
a Grad Cohort for women.
But a year ago we offered
the first URMD Grad Cohort,
which was a Co-ed Grad Cohort for
under-represented minorities
and people with disabilities.
We just set the date
and the place,
it's going to be in
March keep an eye out,
March 2019 will be the second
of those URMD Grad Cohorts.
>> So, now, I may have understood
your question or comment
a little bit differently.
The way I understood
it in connection
with the diversity and
its impact on innovation is
bringing in people with
different abilities-
>> Good point.
>> -into the creative process,
into the idea generation in
the innovation process and I
think it's absolutely key.
For the same reasons that
we've talked about that,
what you get at the end,
is born accessible.
It's born with
multiple perspective,
it's born with the ability
to function and be
useful for a broader range
of people in a broader
range of contexts.
So, thank you so much
for bringing that up.
>> Great point, yes. Anybody
else have a question?
We deal with? Well, all right,
so thank you panelists.
Let's thank our
panelists for yay.
>> For yay.
>> For yay. All
right, thank you all.